COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I take a look at saving
some costs by using
a different network tier.
Will our performance stack up?
Stay tuned to find out.
If you take a hard look at your
application's network data,
you'll find that it's
not consistent in terms
of priority.
I mean, it's really nice that
your app can use a two terabyte
connection for video,
but do you really
need that much performance when
uploading your log content?
Or better yet,
does it make sense
to pay for that performance
when uploading your log content?
This is where Google
Cloud's new Standard Tier
networking comes in.
It offers lower throughput,
higher latency, and lower cost
than the default Premium Tier.
The difference
between the two tiers
has to do with how long packets
stay on the public internet.
Now, see, in the
Premium Tier, packets
enter Google's networks as
close to the user as possible
and then travel on
Google's backbones
before getting to the VM.
The Standard Tier,
on the other hand,
allows packets to enter Google's
networks as close to the VM
as possible, spending
more time traveling
on the public internet.
And since it's spending less
time on Google's network,
it costs less as a result.
Now, as a developer,
there's two big questions.
How much performance
am I losing,
and how much money am I saving?
To figure out the
first question,
let's take a look at
the worst case scenario,
transferring data
across an ocean.
I set up two VMs in US central
one and configured one of them
for the Premium Tier and the
other for the Standard Tier.
Then from a non-GCP
machine in the UK,
fetched a 100k image from
each instance about 500 times.
The graph here shows the
Premium Tier is about 41%
faster on average than
the Standard Tier.
Now, we can also run this test
in the best case scenario,
where the client and the
server are geographically
closer to each other.
In this configuration,
we can see
that the Standard
Tier is only about 8%
slower than the Premium Tier.
Now, at the time of this
video, GCP's tiered network
is still in alpha, so lots
of stuff is still in flux.
As such, keep an eye
on the official site
for more information.
And if you want to know
more about our tests
or how you could use the
Standard Tier to save
your app some money,
check out the article
linked in the description
below, and don't
forget to check out the rest
of our Cloud Performance Atlas
content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]